[موسيقى]
إنها ساعة الغداء في هذا المطعم في
دبي وZ dastani هنا ليطلب طعامه
المعتاد، أحصل على مناشدات s spor s،
على عكس عملاء المطعم الآخرين،
فهو على وشك الحصول على خصم بنسبة 18% لمجرد
أنه اشترك في تطبيق مكافآت جديد
يسمى موجو أستخدم البطاقات أستخدم
القسائم هنا
ما هو هنا حقًا أه مثير للاهتمام أنه أمر
بسيط للغاية، فأنت تدفع لك ببساطة باي
حسنًا ولن يلاحظ أحد أه
أنك تطلب خصمًا بدلاً من
الاعتماد على الكوبونات الورقية أو
الرموز الرقمية  يحصل مستخدمو MIM Mojo على أموال مباشرة
في بطاقات Visa الخاصة بهم عندما
ينفقون مع تجار التطبيق عبر
خدمات البيع بالتجزئة لمشروبات الطعام وأكثر من ذلك،
والفرق هو أنه يتم أتمتة
التجربة التي لا يضطر المستهلكون
أبدًا إلى تذكرها للإعلان عن
هويتهم وأنهم  عندما نستخدم
أحد العروض، وحقيقة أن التجار
لا يحتاجون إلى تدريب موظفيهم، فهذا
أمر غير مرئي بالنسبة لهم، فنحن نفعل كل شيء من أجلهم، فنحن
نحل مشكلة،
مشكلة حقيقية ونحل هذه
المشكلة من خلال الهوس  تشير
تجربة استطلاع حديث أجرته
منصة الولاء Wildfire Systems Inc إلى
أن ثمانية من كل 10 مستهلكين يفضلون
مكافآت الاسترداد النقدي بدلاً من الأميال أو
النقاط نظرًا لارتفاع الأسعار
والتضخم وفكرة أنهم يستطيعون
استرداد بعض أموالهم مما
قد يقلل بعد ذلك من  أصبحت التكلفة وزيادة القدرة على
تحمل تكاليف المنتجات
أكثر أهمية. يمكنك التفكير في جميع
الخدمات التي تحصل عليها باستخدام بطاقتك
الائتمانية أو مع شركات الطيران الناشئة، ويمكن أن تلعب
دورًا كبيرًا في تسريع هذا العرض
للمستهلكين أه رقميًا ومع التكنولوجيا
مثل الهاتف المحمول العالمي  ينمو سوق الكوبونات ويقدر
محلل الصناعة العالمية Inc
أنه سيصل إلى
1.6 تريليون دولار أمريكي بحلول عام 2030، وقد حصلنا على
التحقق من شركائنا Master
Guard وVisa وأعتقد أن
التحقق الحقيقي سيأتي بمرور الوقت حيث
نقوم بتسجيل المزيد والمزيد من
الشركاء التجاريين  ويأتي المستهلكون
حتى ذلك الحين لتناول العشاء مثل Zia الذي كان
بالفعل أفضل مستخدم لوجبة غداء MIM Mojo، وقد
أصبح أكثر ربحية قليلاً
[موسيقى]